this is what dreams are made of yeah
well it was what dreams are made of the
Lizzie McGuire revival at Disney Plus
that was recently put on hold
it feels very surreal to be honest now
details about the script have been
revealed and it might just be the not so
Disney storyline that caused the studio
to pump the brakes according to The
Hollywood Reporter who got their hands
on a copy of the script for Episode one
it quote acknowledges the existence of
sex with cheating as a central plot
point yeah like I said not so Disney
after the show was put on hold
Hilary Duff weighed in hitting up her
insta story sharing this pic of a
headline confirming the love Simon TV
show was pulled from Disney Plus for not
being family-friendly guess I'll be
going now right above it Hilary wrote
quote sounds familiar
hmm and if that subtle message wasn't
enough to make you go oh damn she really
spelled it out with this post a writing
in part quote I'd be doing a disservice
to everyone by limiting the realities of
a 30 year olds journey to live under the
ceiling of a PG rating adding it's
important to me that just as her
experience as a preteen teenager
navigating her life were authentic her
next chapters are equally as real and
relatable I think it's really gonna be
fun to go on on the journey with her at
30 and you know it's the same Lizzie but
she's an adult it's it's definitely fun
and a little challenging and also so
familiar at the same time this all comes
just a couple months after Disney Plus
confirmed that the creator and executive
producer of the show had left the
revival in January a Disney spokesperson
told et quote fans have a sentimental
attachment to Lizzie McGuire and high
expectations for a new series after
filming two episodes we concluded that
we need to move in a
creative direction and are putting a new
lens on the series
we also learned at the time that the
show was being put on hold while they
looked for a new showrunner he was the
first to break the news that a Lizzie
revival could happen you recently said
that you would love to revisit Lizzie
McGuire it's been over 15 years since
the movie came out have there been any
conversations yes what's happening is
that ago yeah
since then Hillary shared a lot about
the new show with et she has gained a
lot of confidence and she has a really
cool career and you know she's still I
think she's still gonna be faced with
challenging things we're in middle
school those challenging things seemed
funny and simple but relatable at the
time and I think now in your 30s it's
gonna be the same way but it's like
slightly heavier slightly bigger things
to deal with like she doesn't have kids
yet and she you know she there's some
surprises in the first episode that I
also don't want to give away animated
Lizzie does she have an updated look I'm
like am I giving stuff away I don't know
she's gonna she's gonna stay the same
which i think is is the right thing to
do right it's like that pink top it's so
iconic and like platform flip-flops
yeah those like rocket dog flip-flops I
don't know if anyone knows those but
yeah she has an epic return and I'm I'm
so excited for everyone to I think she's
really gonna be a lot of the comic
relief in the show I'm still hopeful
that we could see a grown up Lizzie on
our TV and Hillary's working on it guys
she even pleaded with Disney on
Instagram to let them move the show to
Hulu so they could explore those mature
storylines of course et will be the
first to bring you all the latest on the
revival
so make sure to stay locked right here
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens and
I'll see you soon
[Music]